hey everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily so I believe that
every single human being is capable of
extraordinary things when they embrace
who they truly are Evans currently an
investor in my business and he's helping
me grow my coaching and speaking
practice and I'm inviting all of you
guys to join me on my startup journey so
living the extraordinary life means that
you're out there saying yes to a bunch
of different things and following your
curiosity and really jumping into the
unknown because what's the alternative
you're gonna live your entire life
wondering what if what if you took that
leap of faith what if you said yes to
that opportunity what if you started
that business what if you started to
have a relationship and it sucks in that
cycle over and over again what if and
regretting not taking steps towards a
life that you really want and at the
same time when you are living life in
the unknown happens you are going to
face challenges that you did not expect
and you may not know what to do
so the answer is not to give up on the
life that you really want the answer is
to actually trust yourself trust are you
gonna figure it out trust that you have
all the answers within you so for me I
met a guy by the name of Dave and I fell
in love and I decided to take a leap of
faith and jump into the unknown and move
to Thailand with him and along the way
some happened to me some unexpected
challenges I was faced with you know I
came into this country thinking that
everybody would be able to speak English
and they didn't and I don't speak a word
of Thai I could not find reliable
internet in the first couple of weeks
and it's not a problem for a lot of
people but when the entire business is
based online it's a huge problem and to
top it all off I had a urinary tract
infection and that really
and that's when I decided that I really
needed to trust myself trust I had all
the answers within me and I'm gonna
figure it out
so what did I do I figured out I went in
the internet cafe to help with the
internet issues
I use Google Translate to help with the
language barrier and I really trusted
myself when it came to the hospital
because I knew what when my body was
going through it was able to communicate
that clearly for the hospital staff and
that's a thing for you you may be facing
something that you've never faced with
before you're like I jump into the
unknown and now have this pilot to deal
with so what do I do now and I'm telling
you this that you have all the answers
within you to figure things out and you
may be looking at me it's like well you
know it's easy for you to say because
you're in personal development your your
coach and of course you have all the
answers that's not always the truth I
had to figure things out on my own and I
want to share certain things that I have
done to train myself in understanding
that I do have all the answers within me
so here are the three things that I did
to help myself so the first thing is to
reframe your questions a lot of the
times we are stuck we ask ourselves the
same questions over and over and over
again in a very defeated tone why not
replace that with an empowering tone so
for example you may be asking yourself
the question like how do I get myself
out of this situation and you're really
defeated your your body language is
showing that your tone is showing that
and it's amazing how changing your body
language and changing your tone to
really help you find the solution so why
not replace it with this with an
empowering one so say that you know how
can I get myself out of the situation
and get excited about the fact that
you're gonna find solution and you have
a within you and you to surprise
yourself of all the things they're gonna
be coming out of you to help you get out
of the situation the second thing is to
look at your past challenges you may
have not experienced this particular
challenge before but you have faced
other challenges in your path this is no
different the common denominator
you you are the one who got yourself out
of the situation so take an inventory of
all the accomplishments that you have
done and achieved despite of all the
challenges and trust yourself that
you're gonna be just fine and you're
gonna figure things out and you know
overcome these challenges the last thing
is to look at inspirational models and
look at someone who has been through a
similar situation as you if you an
entrepreneur who's facing a rejection
issue right now and you don't know how
to get yourself out of it maybe you look
at someone who is an entrepreneur who
was able to overcome the fear of
rejection not only are you able to model
after them and find solutions to help
your situation but what you can do is
use their stories to inspire you to
overcome them because if they can do it
so can you now living an extraordinary
life is an amazing feeling and it's so
meaningful and I love every minute of it
and I want the same for you but at the
same time you are gonna be Saints with
challenges they haven't faced for before
and in peace funk at time and it's
something that people don't talk about
you know I've jumped into the unknown
everything is amazing and life is great
no there is a big portion of it that
really sucks and that's okay it's okay
to go through those periods of time it's
okay to feel like crap it's okay to feel
those emotions so the answer is not to
just give up in like while it's not
worth it it is worth it if it's towards
a life that you really want you just
have to really trust yourself they're
gonna figure everything out because the
alternative is that you're not living
the life that you want you can spend the
entire life regretting with what ends
and I have a special shout-out for Cindy
Joseph Cindy thank you so much for
writing the comments on my last episode
you support me a lot to me and finally
the question of the day is what is that
one thing you are going to do today to
start living that extraordinary life
leave in the comments below and I'll
join in on the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me oh my gosh
I'm in freakin Thailand and it's amazing
I'm growing I'm changing I'm learning
and it gives me the comfort in knowing
that all of you guys are there for me
every step of the way so thank you so
much again and I'll see you guys raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details